remember like third grade yes
when guardian leviosa is what everyone
used to do when when god is all they
ever said going shut up john's the
biggest harry potter fan i know everyone
biggest harry potter fan i know now's
the time to be dude biggest harry potter
fan he's all about jk rowling
shut up about it yeah man everything she
says is gospel to me but he's read every
book he's seen every movie five times
including the crimes of grindelwald i've
seen that one the most because it was my
favorite we got our trailer here for the
secrets of dumbledore the first thing
we'll talk about is grindelwald right
when the trailer is done no beating
around the bush here
[Music]
if you listen carefully enough
the past whispers to you
we're here to see i was dumbledore
[Music]
this is the team that's going to take
down the most dangerous visit in over a
century
yes yes yes yes a zoologist this
indispensable assistant
was a descendant from a very old family
a school teacher
okay
and a muggle dumbledore should i give
you something
no
way who wouldn't like houses what does
he gonna get a walk
how's that gonna work
[Music]
things are not quite what they appear
don't forget the b side
oh yeah
okay
[Music]
one might call it that
correct three points to hufflepuff
yeah you would be 45 to gryffindor
that's right just because
you're doing yours forgotten the wrong
hand
mess you up why did you guess it
look out for christmas
good old kowalski it looks good it looks
fun and charming brought me more
goodwill than my uh recollection of the
crimes of grindelwald left with me so
that's a good thing i mean yeah the
crimes of grindelwald had uh had good
trailers too ultimately did not like
that film it's the first harry potter
movie i actively did not enjoy i thought
the finale was good i've seen it twice
it was okay uh and i thought
the finale was good and i think johnny
depp was one of the best parts of that
movie yeah i mean if you guys were
around when the casting and the firing
occurred you know where we stand it's
pretty messed up wb dun dun johnny depp
some dirty mads mickelson it's a weird
feeling because when i see him here he
looks awesome i don't like crimes at
grindelwald i thought johnny depp was
one of the better parts of that movie
same time i'd be a total liar to you
guys if i was to sit here and go i'm not
excited for mads mickelson because i
think maz mickelson is an amazing actor
i've seen a decent amount of his movies
i've seen all of hannibal and i'm like
yeah he's from with the brief knowledge
i have of grindelwald i think he's
perfectly cast for the role yes it's
absolutely in his wheelhouse and the
idea of him and jude law bouncing off
each other just sounds awesome to me and
it very much is in the mads mickelson
wheelhouse in fact in some ways it kind
of looks like an older johnny deputy in
like in this trailer
it's not as made up it's a very
different look a big part of what
probably makes it even more interesting
to me is the fact that it is the
controversy surrounding it the recasting
of johnny depp puts you more of a
critical eye on it of let's see if he's
better
or if he's just as good for a lot of
people maybe not for everyone but for a
lot of people i think that that's going
to definitely be present when watching
this movie a little bit of comparison or
a little bit more extra critical
attention i'm very interested to see
what he does with the role absolutely i
mean mads mickelson terrific actor he
can definitely play a role like this
it's not like the most like oh man he's
gonna stretch his legs and show me
something i've never seen before i just
feel like he's gonna pretty much nail
the part and i feel like it helps them
that colin farrell was original you know
spoilers if you haven't seen the first
movie but you know grindelwald
shape-shifts out of being colin farrell
so i feel like even though there's
probably some explanation or something
audiences might need to be fully on
board with this it's already kind of
motivated by that so it could be a lot
weirder to have a different face on the
same character than it is here now jude
law is like wonderful casting for
dumbledore like it does as much as i am
sort of cynical of like i'm wary about
going off road and being like we got to
keep this thing going let's dig into
dumbledore's past like these things are
hinted at in the book and i think yeah
jude law is a great pick to you know
jump back into young dumbledore's life
now i'm just curious as to how they're
going to continue making newt and his
crew feel essential uh some of my
biggest issues with crimes of
grindelwald had to do with the
maintenance of those characters and the
sort of willy-nilly changing of their
motivations and things like that that's
what i really hope to see because part
of my favorite aspects of the first
fantastic beasts movie were newt and
jake and queenie and uh you know
katherine waterston
uh all them together uh the new players
look fun too and it's always nice to get
back into the world of harry potter like
as a cinematic world i could just you
know leave it on in the background and
want to feel like i'm hanging out there
the whole time so it's always a treat to
get to go back is a decent first trailer
it's not selling me on like oh man this
is gonna be the next big voldemort
adventure i've been waiting for it
certainly is leaving me with a sense of
goodwill based off of my skepticism from
the last movie so
i'm pleased at the moment
yeah it looks fine
yeah it's you know
looks fine
i mean i'm excited to see the stories of
dumbledore with him actually being
involved in the action and going out on
the streets is sort of like this very
like mission we're almost in the brink
of war type of scenario explore their
romance you cowards and jacob kowalski
getting a wand yeah seems very
very weird did they establish anything
at all of him having magical abilities
nope that's what yeah like i don't know
how what is he gonna do with him is that
he's human yeah exactly
what is he gonna do with it i mean
you know he's often a scene stealer yeah
that is true i mean squibs have hard
enough time using ones how is the muggle
gonna do it with any sort of uh accuracy
the beast part sometimes feels like an
afterthought it does it absolutely the
first one it wasn't last one and then
even in this trailer well no the first
movie they're like hey it's about you
know this guy and he's collecting these
beasts and yeah like there's trouble
brewing in the background and then the
second movie is like oh we need another
voldemort and we need to make it about
that kind of thing about everyone
fighting the biggest baddest guy around
i mean not that i guess you could build
an entire just like harry potter
franchise out of a little pamphlet like
fantastic beasts where to find them but
at the same time it would be nice if it
felt like those were a little more
essential to the very true very true
well guys are you excited for the
secrets of dumbledore we're gonna watch
it either way it's one of those things
you know we're just gonna have our
ticket regardless sure yeah we'll be
there i'm here for harry potter put her
on hbo max same day subscribe click that
bell hit that like button thanks for
tuning in guys we'll see you soon